false bleaching and something in jazz
and six victims all and this match but this
pick up when it comes to see the streets
culture of impunity the institute has
carried out several studies
on sexism is therefore there the finding was
when  Even staggering, therefore, this analysis
has shown that no
country has comprehensive legislation
on sexism or on sexist stereotypes.
We must fight against what is at the
root of this discrimination, but at the root
of this discrimination there are the  ideas
that are anchored in our heads and the
gender stereotypes that therefore produce
both what I would call
unconscious sexism and
displayed sexism for the person who experiences a
behavior with which they are
not comfortable daring to say it right away  it's
very complicated for some people
sometimes you're not very skilful but you
have to dare to do it or dare to ask
for help to learn how to do
it that's one and for the other the one who
receives the remark  ue t1 when you say that i
don't feel comfortable not
going into a reflection on
whether it's justified or not but
to hear the message is to
control oneself indian ok here i hear the
message is with this  nobody there I control myself
I take it upon myself I stop it's
in India the constraint you have to manage to
convince the men who will be the
big winners of the deconstruction of
stereotypes first of all because they will
work in a
more balanced institution  more harmonious but
also because they themselves are the
victim of these stereotypes
they must be convinced if
we have a culture that values
teeism the fact of being present regar
less of what we are doing there
a man who is going to leave at 5 p.m. to
pick up his children he will be
doubly guilty he would be guilty
with regard to availability he will be
guilty with regard to the qualities that are
usually attributed to men
so there you have it  t the famous word
of the poet the woman is the future of
the man
me I think that it is necessary that the man
is the future of the equality men women
and children and approximately
affirmative in perfect gentleman dairy
milk interest of action
this  closing moment of a
top pick and go walk subtitle is dead